E aí
se
imagina-se num piscar de olhos a sua
vida o seu destino mudassem para sempre
pois vem exatamente isso que eu vim aqui
falar para vocês eu nasci numa cidade de
interior era uma criança muito agitada
muito alegre muito feliz no ambiente
familiar sensacional com carinho com
amor é aquela criança que não parava que
sempre estava ali correndo pulando
brincando
agitada o tempo todo gostava de praticar
todas as atividades todos os esportes
natação atletismo futebol
handebol basquete judô ou tudo que tinha
ali próximo a onde eu morava eu gostava
de fazer e brincava na rua com as
crianças como era de costume na minha
época e o tempo foi passando o tempo
passou eu comecei a treinar ginástica
olímpica Adorei o esporte me dediquei
aqueles potes por três anos tive alguns
problemas não consegui continuar a
modalidade fui para o atletismo
há 11 anos eu conheci o grande amor da
minha vida o jiu-jitsu esporte que eu
pratico até hoje eu treino e dentro do
tatame eu pensava eu 14 anos mais fraco
mais leve como que eu vou ser melhor que
os outros Como que você melhor que
aqueles mais experientes mais forte do
que eu e foi ali que eu entendi que eu
tinha que ser melhor comigo mesmo a cada
dia a cada treino não melhor que os
outros e o jiu jitsu me mostrou ali a
questão de disciplina respeito e
hierarquia e respeito pelo adversário
espelho pela pessoa que tava estava ali
treinando comigo espelho pelos mais
graduados e tudo isso eu carrego comigo
até os dias de hoje a gente pensa que a
gente tem que evoluir a gente pensa que
a gente tem que ser campeão que a gente
tem que conquistar medalhas conquistar
títulos mas na verdade a maior conquista
é você evoluir como ser humano evoluir
como pessoa e fazer o seu melhor Ah e
tudo isso eu fui trabalhando fui
crescendo e aos 21 anos de idade foi um
estudo mudou na minha vida eu sofri um
acidente
me deixou paraplégico onde eu perdi o
movimento das pernas
E aí
É nesse momento desse dia em diante
toda aquele aprendizado no Tatame e
Respeito hierarquia e disciplina eu
teria colocar em prática
momento mais difícil mas tenso momento
crucial na minha vida onde eu tive Total
apoio da minha família os meus amigos
onde eu entende o Real significado da
vida de continuar e acreditar e nunca
desistir E é isso que eu quero trazer
para você hoje a importância de você
acreditar que você superar e você não
ficar preocupado com coisas ruins que
momentos ruins dificuldades problemas
todos temos
É mas o que você faz com o problema o
que você faz com aquela situação difícil
você senta reclama lamenta ou você
supera Você acredita
aos 21 anos de idade uma cadeira de
rodas eu entende o Real significado de
uma vida em cima de uma cadeira de rodas
pois quando eu tinha uns três quatro
cinco anos de idade eu sonhava ser um
Ayrton Senna e acelerar em pilotar está
um Kart no carro de automobilismo eu
realizei esse sonho depois do acidente
depois está numa cadeira de rodas Então
imagina
e tudo mudou
é o jeito de andar que eu tive que
reaprender a andar antes andava em pé
com as pernas
daquele momento em diante de uma cadeira
de rodas
momento de realizar o sonho de ser
piloto estará acelerando
mas em paralelo de lembrar de todo o
aprendizado Satan
naquele momento era tratando a pista o
quimono o macacão a faixa o capacete
tudo isso depois de um acidente depois
ficar uma cadeira de rodas então é esse
significado da vida acreditar superar
não desistir e tudo isso a gente só
tem quando a gente acredita em se é isso
que você precisa para se realizar como
pessoa para realizar sonhos atingir
objetivos eu realizei alguns sonhos
atingir objetivos ele é o sonho de
conquistar títulos conquistar medalhas
está numa pista de acelerar o momento
agora é de realizar sonhos de outras
pessoas levar tudo que eu aprendi todos
os conhecimentos toda experiência que eu
tive e tenho na minha vida ajudar outras
pessoas a realizar ações fazer com que
essas pessoas
acreditem que as podem
e hoje o meu maior sonho é motivar
pessoas eu ver você por exemplo
acreditando no seu melhor mas às vezes
eu tenho uma história triste todo mundo
tem história triste e ele já tenho uma
dificuldade eu tenho um problema todo
mundo tem um problema todo mundo tem uma
dificuldade mas o que nós vamos fazer
com esse problema que nós vamos fazer
vamos fazer com essa dificuldade e aí na
sua cabeça Acredite batalhe Lud planeja
Como que você vai chegar até o objetivo
final até o realização desse sonho
Eu acredito em você acredito que a fé a
força de vontade move montanha acredite
que você ser grato por tudo que você tem
na sua vida você vai realizar os outros
objetivos
dificuldades vão aparecer problemas vão
aparecer Mas você vai ficar sentado
acomodado ou você vai utilizar as rodas
da vida para chegar lá na frente para
realizar o seu sonho eu poderia estar
sentado na cadeira de rodas reclamando
desistindo mas não eu usei a cadeira de
rodas para crescer para evoluir para ser
melhor e é isso que o quero passar para
você é isso que eu quero passar para
todas as pessoas
Independente da sua condição
independente do que acontecer na sua
vida ele a sua cabeça Faça o seu melhor
Se dedique e nunca desista e olhe para
frente passado uma história triste teve
um problema lá atrás teve uma coisa ruim
mas você superou você já passou por
aquele momento e agora vamos lá já o
futuro um planejar o que vai ver ali na
frente um plano já o próximo sonhos o
próximo sonho vamos realizar vamos
batalhar é isso que você tem que pensar
é isso que você tem que levar para sua
vida e foi isso que eu vivi depois do
meu acidente
realizando os meus sonhos meus objetivos
e trazendo sempre pessoas do bem para
perto então eu fiz as minhas as minhas
escolhas e você já fez a sua fica essa
reflexão pense escolha da melhor maneira
possível